there are caped crusaders galactic  guardian and amazing web players but for  over a decade only one hero dared to be  wimpy  hmm the Wimpy Kid there's one thing I've  learned from my usual day you can say  and zero control over your own life I  was excited about the great pet me road  trip 14 in a car together this summer  whereas those in Indianapolis this  weekend it only she winches away  tomorrow we write the laundry he's going  further changing destinations then he  ever gone before and becoming a rebel I  need to file a missing-persons reports  me what do your parents think about you  guys coming to the expo to play video  game oh they have no idea frankly girls  are a little slow actually I'd like to  report a double murder from 20th century  five  the WIMP will ride well you said you  want to get the boat on the water of the  summer Diary of a Wimpy Kid the long  haul  you